[Music]
[Laughter]
Yeah, I wanted to mention something about HIV.
Dr. Pete may have seen that study. I think it came out around 2014.
Of course, it didn't hit mainstream media, but it showed that, at least the authors claimed that,
you cannot develop AIDS if you're HIV positive.
So you cannot develop AIDS unless there's high levels of endotoxin in your blood.
And then there was a subsequent study, I think in 2018, which showed that
the single most reliable predictor of death, of all-cause mortality in HIV-positive people,
was the level of this protein called soluble CD14.
It's abbreviated SCD14, and that is the most reliable biomarker of endotoxin levels in the blood.
And for some reason, I never see virologists talk about the role of endotoxin in viral disease,
in multi-organ failure, and in septic shock, while in reality, it seems like all of these things
are directly caused by endotoxin.
Yeah, I'm inclined to think that even cancer is largely an endotoxin problem.
Chronic, year after year, bad food irritating the intestine,
causing increased histamine and serotonin and estrogen,
a constant stream of endotoxin flowing through the system,
shaking up chromosomes, creating inflammation, fatiguing the repair systems.
Finally, when the repair systems are down to a certain extent,
the cancers that are constantly popping up stop being removed.
So if you don't die of acute sepsis,
then heart disease and cancer, I think, are the result of chronic exposure to the endotoxin.
So would you say the specific organ or tissue where the cancer appears,
the apparently localized nature, even though we know it's a systemic problem,
the apparently localized nature is simply because that particular organ or tissue
was the most energetically compromised?
That's why it took a hold there?
Yeah.
When I've mentioned the idea of systemic disease to cancer doctors or patients,
they really have a hard time, just can't grasp.
They've been so indoctrinated with the idea that it's a clone
that develops one single mutant cell, develops into the clone,
and so it's by definition the most localized thing conceivable.
It's platonically localized.
But way back 80 or 90 years, people have been seeing pre-cancerous gradations
surrounding any tumor.
If you look at all of the signs, stem cell signals, all of the inflammatory cytokines,
disturbed chromosome balance, all of those things are increased in a gradient.
The field concept of cancer goes way back 200 years almost,
but it just hasn't been acceptable because of this platonistic genetic determinism,
clonal descent of each tumor.
Have you seen the study that came out in 2015?
Basically, we made huge waves across the oncology community.
If there is such a thing, and it basically said,
"For over 100 years, we've been wrong.
We've been calling it the Warburg effect, but now it seems that the effect is the cause as well."
In other words, metabolic disturbances, and specifically lactic acid,
precede the genomic abnormalities that are seen in cancer cells
and actually the cause of them, not the other way around.
Lactic acid creates a reduced state, shifts the balance towards increased sulfhydryl,
NADH ratio to NAD,
and all of the electronic and energetic properties of cancer are initiated
just by putting a lot of lactic acid into the system.
Yeah.
It was posted on one of the biggest social media sites,
and you could see doctors chiming in,
and some of them being panicky and saying,
"Oh my God, if this is true, it means in my practice as an oncologist,
I've been killing people."
And others are saying, "Well, it's too early.
Let's see genetics.
We haven't heard the last of genetics yet.
Let's give genetics a chance.
Maybe we'll find a way to treat it genetically."
But overall, the mood was--
Well, it was pessimistic for the oncologist,
but the general public that was reading this thread and responding
seemed to be pretty ecstatic because people immediately caught on the fact
that if cancer is metabolic and it's this continuous field,
then it can probably be reversed.
You don't need to subject yourself to this torture
that your oncologist is giving you and likely killing you.
There are other ways.
And the doctors were heavily arguing against it in that same thread,
saying, "No, people, if you choose the metabolic route,
you'll be killing yourselves.
You're signing your debt warrants.
You should stay with a traditional therapist until we know more."
Did you ever read Max Gerson's book?
I think it's called 59 Cases.
Coffee enemas were one of his staples.
He generally gave people thyroid
and tried to get their metabolism towards oxidative energy production.
But cleaning the intestine was probably his single most effective thing,
because even if he sometimes had an old person who was very debilitated,
he would sometimes give them a coffee enema every hour around the clock
and get them out of bed to wash their intestine again.
And he actually cured numerous advanced cases of cancer
that he documented with photographs.
I think chronically keeping the endotoxin down
gives the recuperative system a great chance.
So that would explain largely why recent studies with tetracycline antibiotics,
especially doxycycline, are reporting such remarkable effects?
Yes. In 1965, which was the first time,
some doctor sent me an argument that he was curing cancer with antibiotics.
I didn't at that time think of it in terms of cutting out the endotoxin,
but people have been doing it repeatedly over several decades.
I have to send you a press release from Harvard University.
I think it's from the early 90s.
It's about a lady that ran a cancer lab there.
It was a popular press article.
It said, "Dr. Johnson is capable of curing mice with lethal leukemia
every time she wants to."
How does she do that? By giving them tetracycline.
And then the question is, "Why can't this be done in people?"
She said, "Because it's not FDA approved."
I thought to myself, "What a stupid excuse.
What is the antibiotic going to do to these terminally ill people?
Kill them? They're dying anyway.
Why not try something that's already approved for usage in people
and it's known to be relatively safe?
Why do we have to wait on the bureaucracy to give us approval to live?
Why can't this be tried by good-natured doctors?"
I've known doctors who were declared imminently dying in hospital.
They wanted to try something on their own.
The supervising doctors took their stuff away from them,
wouldn't let them experiment.
Even though they were said to have only 48 hours left to live,
they couldn't experiment on themselves.
I remember there was a neurologist who got a neuroglial dystoma
and he started injecting himself with some kind of a virus or bacteria
to give himself fever because he read that fever sometimes cured cancer.
He was immediately declared mentally unfit.
They basically committed this doctor who used to work in this hospital,
they locked him up in his own hospital and he died a few weeks later.
There have been a couple of studies in which people,
they accidentally noticed that women who were given an antibiotic course,
among other things, they recovered from their headaches.
But they did blood tests and found that before the antibiotic,
they had high estrogen and cortisol and low progesterone.
After the course of antibiotics, their progesterone went up
and both cortisol and estrogen went down,
both of which would favor recovery from cancer.
Cortisol is weakening your immune processes, for example,
and estrogen is stimulating the cell growth.
In rats, the same thing was observed.
A course of antibiotics lowers cortisol and estrogen and increases progesterone.
So the coffee enema or the antibiotic or high fiber diet,
all of those things are actually remedying your hormone situation.
Did you know that cortisol is given to pretty much any cancer patients?
It's kind of like a standard treatment?
Along with morphine.
And morphine, yes.
And morphine increases histamine release.
And histamine is a powerful tumor promoter.
So they usually adjust the dose so that they're dead
before they notice that the tumor has grown faster.
I just never ceased to amaze me.
The explanation of the doctors, because I used to work in the medical field,
was that the patient has inflammation and edema,
and we need to reduce it with a cortisol.
Aren't there other safer anti-inflammatory methods?
Because even as ignorant as some doctors are,
some of them do know that cortisol does not seem to be helping the tumor patients.
They're almost using it because by definition,
that's the powerful anti-inflammatory they have on file, and they have to use it.
Ray, would you put Paul Ehrlich in the pantheon of people that have ruined science?
[Laughter]
So Weissman, Paul Ehrlich.
And Ehrlich was the same guy that did the estrogen receptor stuff, is that right?
He popularized the whole idea of lock-on P receptor specificity.
Go ahead.
That whole receptor idea is perfect for selling chemicals.
Every chemical can have a receptor, and so it's perfect for the chemical industry.
And the holistic, ongoing whirlwind picture of the organism,
where, for example, a large dose of a chemical can have an opposite effect
of a small dose, those contradictory anti-receptor pictures
are no good for the chemical industry.
I have a question about the whole receptor thing.
I'm sure you've probably noticed this yourself,
but I looked at all of the hormones that are currently known,
and then I also looked at the receptor and the receptor structure.
There is a significant overlap in terms of the amino acid sequence
and the structure of the various receptors.
So even though, let's say, a pharmaceutical company may claim
that they've developed this extremely selective, say, estrogen agonist,
if you go back and look at the other studies done by other groups,
you'll see invariably that the substance that they claim is extremely selective
is invariably acting on other receptors as well.
So my question is, is it even possible to develop a truly selective receptor compound,
given that the various receptors have so much overlap?
No, I don't think so.
The whole idea of receptors derives from Ehrlich,
and I think it's just right down to its foundation corrupt.
St. George reviewed in one of his books ideas that Pavlov was familiar with
around the turn of the century, the idea that the dose determines the effect.
Like a small amount of caffeine is sedative,
a large amount is stimulating, and an even larger amount is narcotic.
And the dose of a sedative, a small dose, will be a stimulant,
a larger dose, a sedative.
And the typical curve has been tested on hundreds of different substances,
and it consistently contradicts the idea of a specific receptor doing a specific thing.
The only way you can imagine that three-phase curve working
is if you think of the cell as substance or characteristic qualities and substance.
You have to think of something which can move from one phase to another,
potentially a series of phases, each phase having a characteristic behavior.
So the differentiation occurs in the cytoplasm as a whole,
and that state of the cytoplasm evokes the expression
or stabilizes the expression of the genes that are appropriate for that state.
But by thinking in terms of physical states,
you can visualize the quantity as reaching a threshold.
A cooperative phase transition happens when many things work in the same direction.
So basically the whole idea of using one substance that will work in only one particular way,
it's hopeless. I mean, basically the organism doesn't work like that.
Yeah, you can create the illusion that it does by setting conditions just exactly right,
and then you can get the apparent specific interaction and reaction,
but it's a purely artificial setup.
Have you seen the recent news about the resurgence of estrogen,
of hormone replacement therapy with estrogen in menopausal women?
They're trying to kind of put down all the findings of the Women's Health Initiative study
and try to reintroduce estrogen as therapy.
Yeah, in 1973 or '74, I saw a resurgence,
and about every five or ten years the actual science makes a little headway.
The big headway was the Women's Health Initiative,
and within five years the people at Stanford were instrumental in explaining
why estrogen didn't really cause cancer, strokes, heart attacks, and so on.
Their favorite explanation is it's really progesterone.
Originally, estrogen was recognized as doing certain things to the organism,
and they identified the estrogen receptor as a major way that it does that,
even though hypoxia in the absence of estrogen will cause the receptor to behave the same.
Estrogen creates hypoxia and activates the estrogen.
Hypoxia alone will do it if something else creates it.
When they needed to explain away that estrogen does everything that it does,
they discovered the estrogen receptor beta,
and it turns out that almost everything that estrogen doesn't do, the beta does.
It stops growth, stops all of the characteristic estrogen behaviors,
and pretty much parallels the actions of progesterone.
Progesterone now is divided into an A and B receptor.
The A receptor is activated by estrogen and inactivates the progesterone B,
but they're just thinking wildly of ways that they can say that progesterone is responsible
for all of the bad stuff that has been blamed on estrogen.
I emailed one of the authors of one of the big papers that's now calling for reintroduction of estrogen as therapy for women,
and I said, "How can we ignore all this science that's pretty much indisputable that estrogen is carcinogenic?"
There is actually a page posted on the website of the National Institutes of Health
which officially defines and declares estrogen as a carcinogen and a mutagen.
I said, "Your own organization says that estrogen is this dangerous chemical."
He said, "Estrogen has non-genomic effects that are actually beneficial,
and if we give it at lower dosages, it acts as a powerful antioxidant
that will remove the need for people to take vitamin E and C,
and it will give them all the benefit for heart protection without actually having the carcinogenic effects."
Ray?
Are you still there, Georgie?
Oh, no. Did we lose Ray?
Maybe we did.
Okay.
It seems like he's there.
Maybe let me hang up and call him back.
Ray, you're not there, right?
Okay, I'm going to hang up, call him back.
These things happen.
I was afraid you were frozen, too.
I was like, "Oh, man, I have a serious problem if everything just froze.
That would be really not good."
I think I finally bored Ray to death, and he's like, "I'm done with this.
You guys keep talking."
Okay, let me call him back.
Unable to add participant is unavailable.
Is it? Does that mean it's giving business to him or something?
I wonder if he's trying to call back the number, which would, I think, be impossible.
I don't know. We'll see.
Okay, everybody, thank you so much.
I think we have like 250 people.
This is obviously the most people we've ever had on here, so that is heartwarming.
I never wanted to get Ray on until I felt real comfortable with the mechanics of the livestream stuff,
and so I feel more comfortable with it, and so I'm happy to have this happen,
and it's everything I ever dreamed of.
Thanks, Georgie, and massive thanks to Ray.
Let me call him back again.
I wonder if there's a time limit on the show.
Ray, you're back. Okay. We lost you for a second.
I didn't hear when it went to bad.
I don't know either, Georgie. Do you remember?
When we lost Ray, it was kind of like a strange  I thought my whole computer froze, but it didn't.
No, I was talking about the reintroduction of estrogen.
I was talking to one of the authors of a big study that came out this year,
and I emailed him and I said, "How can you argue that estrogen is good,
considering that your own organization  I think that person works for the NIH
has a webpage which says estrogen is a carcinogen and a mutagen?
Why would you argue that estrogen needs to be reintroduced and given to women?"
He said, "Estrogen has non-genomic effects that don't involve the estrogen receptor
and acts as a powerful antioxidant.
If we give it to women in the right dosage,
they will obviate the need for them to take massive doses of vitamin E and C,
and it will provide them with this benefit of cardiovascular protection
and everything that these great antioxidants do."
So how can you prevent estrogen from activating these receptors that you know are causing cancer?
He basically said it's the dosage that makes the poison.
So they're thinking that lower-dose estrogen is going to be beneficial,
but I remember you said in several of these letters that a continuous uninterrupted exposure
to a low dose of estrogen is probably more harmful than getting estrogen spikes
every few days or every few weeks.
Yeah, that was Alexander Lipschutz from about 1938 through the 1940s.
He did many animal experiments showing that even very small doses of estrogen,
unless they were interrupted with progesterone,
were carcinogenic not just to the uterus and breast,
but to the lungs, kidneys, brain, every organ,
would eventually develop estrogen-induced cancer.
Well, if cancer is a state of chronic reductive stress
and estrogen is a powerful reductant itself,
doesn't that almost guarantee that estrogen will at the very least contribute to an already established cancer?
Yeah, I don't know of any case where it doesn't.
Okay.
To change gears a little bit, Ray, I feel like you're getting more popular on YouTube and Twitter and things,
and people say all sorts of things about why you do what you do.
And so maybe we could just take a second to say, like, why do you do what you do?
Like, just from, you know, your own words, because so many people just basically make up things.
And so I was just curious about your position on that.
As part of my understanding of what I'm doing here in the world,
checking ideas and looking for new perspectives,
checking what people believe and trying to avoid the bad interpretations that lead to bad actions and results,
it's always part of the same process of looking for something to do.
And maybe just an elevator pitch of your general hypothesis, like what you say on the front of your webpage,
the idea that energy and structure are interdependent at every level.
Like, I made a video about this not fairly recently, but it's like,
because the nutrition world is so stuck on different diets, like, what is your
obviously this whole conversation is about how complex everything is,
and your work gets reduced down to kind of a caricature of, like,
you drink two gallons of milk and two gallons of orange juice and a bag of sugar,
and then you're doing your repeat diet.
So what is your perspective of what maintains health,
and then what is the differentiator into the state of sickness?
There are two simple choices.
One is that the genes have been laid out, have created a blueprint for creating the structures,
and all the energy has to do is help to roll those out,
and once they're in place, just to keep them running.
That orientation leads to the idea that the less you live, the longer you will live.
The idea that you're going to burn up your
the whole apparatus will wear out the faster you use it.
That all comes from the reductionist idea of a machine laid out in genetic blueprints.
It's a machine powered by a Rube Goldberg system, which is 20th century science.
The other picture is the developmental picture that energy flowing from the sun through the atmosphere
is creating structures, that the flow of energy itself generates structures,
and the faster the energy flows, the more complex the structure becomes,
and the more energy is saved in the system in the form of complexity of structure.
The efficiency increases, but the waste is part of what is powering it.
You don't have to think in terms of the efficiency of the system,
because the energy flowing through the system, even though the oxidative apparatus is getting more efficient,
you're building a bigger system faster than the complexity and efficiency accumulates.
It's the speed with which you can waste the energy while responding to it,
building your complexity that is holding up the whole structure.
It's simply a picture of an ecosystem responding physically to energy.
It doesn't violate any of the known physical laws.
It uses them in more intelligent ways than the Rube Goldberg science of membranes, genes, and so on.
This is not some idea that you cooked up on your own.
You feel like you're following in a tradition of people like St. Georgie, like Otto Warburg, like Koch, and others?
Yeah. Even earlier, J.C. Bose was one of my first inspirations.
I have a question. Do you think that this openness to new ideas that these people had,
it was sort of enabled by their relatively faster metabolism?
Or do you think it was more or less childhood experiences that set them to be that way,
to be open to new opportunities and to actually actively seek them out?
I think a good intrauterine environment is a tremendous part of it.
Like Catherine Adolton's patients, the older kids of her patients had 95 average IQ.
Just by treating the mothers with progesterone, her patients' kids had something like 135 average IQ.
Same mother, but better nourishment in utero.
That kind of a head start gives you a lot of energy for absorbing shocks from the oppressive environment.
Okay. A question related to that, to expand a little bit on that.
As I'm sure you're familiar, sick people and sick animals tend to sort of retreat, avoid the real world,
and really limit their spectrum of activity.
Some of them even stop eating and basically they just want to keep to themselves and be left alone.
But considering the fact that novelty and new experiences and being stimulated in the proper way is so very therapeutic,
do you think these sick organisms are making a pathological choice that's not good for them based on their already poor health?
Or do you think it's actually a choice that at least in the short term it's good for them?
Basically, they don't have the energy to meet the demands of the world, so they're retreating and hoping that they'll recover and then they'll come back.
Yeah. Usually there's something specific that has happened.
They've eaten something or caught an infection, got poisoned, and retreat and let the body repair itself.
Paracelsus was one of the first people to put it into practice where he put his pharmacological preparation on the sword that caused the wound
and spared the patient the medication and discovered that patients recovered much better without the medication.
Anytime there's been an opportunity to compare medicated people with unmedicated, the ones without medicine are much healthier.
Like animals, we could just take a week or two to retreat and maybe have a milkshake now and then.
People would be much healthier, more likely to survive to old age.
So I guess initially it would be beneficial to retreat because you want to recover energetic resources, but do you think that over time if this becomes a chronic isolation, self-imposed,
that over time it actually becomes pathological and starts to hurt health because you've retreated so much from the world?
Yeah, there are people who do that, but they need new opportunities as well. The culture isn't rushing to give them healthy, new, interesting opportunities.
In many cases, actually, they retreated because their doctor told them to. They say, "Stay in your room until I call you and tell you it's okay to get out."
To bring it back to politics a little bit, Ray, you think there's a way forward with the system that we have at the moment? You see glimmers of hope.
I remember when you were talking to Gavin for that interview on politics when Trump had just been elected.
It seemed like, okay, this is different, but then over time he seems to have been absorbed into the same kind of stereotypical problems of endless war and things like that.
But you do see a glimmer of hope in that whole system?
Do you know who Ann Coulter is? I think of her as the personification of Gooney reactionary philosophy.
But weirdly, she has made some of the most insightful comments about what's going on now. For example, comparing Bernie and Trump, she pointed out that the very things that he campaigned on but didn't exactly fulfill.
Keeping us out of war, taxing the untaxed corporations like Amazon and the banks, and stopping immigration.
Bernie has identical policies to what people were perceiving as Trump's campaign promises.
She says that he is Trump's real threat and the polls, almost all of the polls are showing Bernie beating Trump by several percentage points.
Most people in the public media, especially the Democrats, don't want to talk about that possibility.
The same people who saw possibility in Trump avoiding war and taxing the giant corporations, that's what they see in Bernie.
So if he could run against Trump, then other realistic things would be at issue.
Maybe Ann Coulter is espousing some of those, you introduced me to the term, but paleoconservative a little bit, some of those ideas?
I don't know what really went through Ann Coulter's mind, but it was more perceptive than I've seen any of the Democrat liberals doing.
Yeah, the paleoconservatives are very consistent on avoiding war, but some of their policies are really dopey.
Well, not to get too deep into a rabbit hole on this, but things like immigration and things, I know there was, I forget the author, but it was a book called Weapons of Mass Migration.
This is not a topic I spend lots of time thinking about, but those types of things to influence the culture, and I know the paleoconservatives are against that.
But again, I'm reading Bucky Fuller and him saying that there shouldn't be borders and things like that.
I agree with that type of view, but I'm also torn between these different points of view of migration and things, and also being in a, living in different countries, it's not very easy to stay anywhere else aside from Mexico or America.
Yeah, Bucky Fuller would say that the corollary is that you stop creating horror experiences at home, like imposing a fascist on Honduras, where the elected president was improving.
He just wanted to raise the minimum wage and barely improve things, but definitely improving.
He was kicked out, Hillary Clinton oversaw putting a fascist in, and all of the progressive labor people trying to get a minimum wage, they're being murdered.
Environmentalists are being murdered, and so obviously it's an improvement for them to try to get in the United States, but simply stopping the oppression of third world countries would stop the immigration, improve conditions.
Hondurans would rather live in Honduras with a better standard of living than going to the US and looking for work.
Erdogan and Turkey are following the Muslim Brotherhood, allying with Al-Qaeda, and ending up creating more refugees and trying to send them to Europe, to force Europe to send an army in to give Syria to him.
If you simply stop supporting the murder and the oppression in places like Turkey and Honduras, you would stop the immigration problem.
And that's from the imperialist US war machine?
Yeah.
I think it's more than the US involved here. I think there are a number of imperialists in this world that are acting in concert with the United States, and often actually spearheading the war in certain places of the world, even more than the United States.
Russia and Turkey, just as you said Dr. Peete, and France and Germany, they all have competing interests in the Middle East. Israel, of course, Saudi Arabia, Iran.
So the United States gets a lot of the blame for being the largest empire of them all, but I think there are plenty of other countries that are at least as evil, and in this specific case probably even more so, than the United States.
Just the number of soldiers maintained in other people's countries, the US is by far the leader.
So I have a question for you. Given everything that we've talked about so far, and politicians getting elected and then getting mired in the very swamp that they pledged to drain, and I've read history, maybe not as extensively as you, but I don't know of a single case of an empire that got reformed.
Do you think that this empire, or any empire, can be reformed? All I saw in history was empires either expanding, reaching their peak, and then either gently fading into oblivion or collapsing almost overnight.
I never saw a case of a peaceful, semi-peaceful, or even constructive reform of an empire.
I think Trump theoretically had that in mind, a controlled collapse of the empire, withdrawing the army more or less quickly.
But the imperialists in the military, for example, don't want to lose their power. But if Bernie could actually run against him, I think between them they would possibly recruit more supporters for bringing the empire down fairly quickly.
What would that entail in your view, bringing down the empire? Would it be simply the end of the world wars that the military machine has started? Or do you mean a more radical social change at home?
If you freed up the Pentagon budget, for example, 90% of it putting the US on a scale with other big countries, that amount of money removed from military destruction could far more than finance any kind of military action.
Any kind of Bernie Sanders programs, free college, healthcare for everyone, good education, healthcare.
I just don't see the powers that be relinquishing that war machine because that is the source of their power. And whoever gets elected, in my view, will be either undermined politically or maybe even worse.
This country has already seen an assassination of a president. And apparently, if you believe other historical sources, attempted assassinations on other presidents that weren't playing ball.
I read JFK, The Unspeakable. That gives a very close view of how Kennedy was backing off from the empire. They didn't want him to back off.
I think even Trump realizes that same mechanism being in action. He has his own secret service, for example.
The Secret Service pretty obviously was involved in killing Kennedy. And Trump knew enough to have his own private security rather than the Secret Service.
I didn't know that much about Trump leading up to the election, but his bailout from some Rothschild family member and then his close association with Sheldon Adelson.
Were there clues that he was not going to follow through with what he was talking about? Because he seems to be totally co-opted. And again, like you said, he's not doing the things that he originally promised to do.
He has repeatedly tried to sign the agreement with the Taliban. Pompeo keeps sabotaging it, but Trump keeps going back and trying to keep the withdrawal on schedule.
So I think more than anyone else in the government, he is making efforts to shut down the war system.
And then how does somebody like Pompeo rise to power? The guy is a total nut. I just listen to some of his speaking and I know it's nothing new, but it's just shocking to even hear him talk about his machinations and things about what's going to happen in the future.
The Armageddon crowd was in Reagan's government too. The interior minister said, "The end is near. Let's mine it all. Get it before the end."
It really seems to be the premise they're all operating on is that the end is coming soon and nothing matters. So that's why maybe that validates endless war and things like that.
That's literally true of a lot of those people like Pompeo.
I wanted to tie in health and the collapse of the empire. Barring any kind of unpredictable collapse that the powers that be inflict on themselves, if we want the reform, so to speak, or the control collapse to come from the people,
many of them, if not most, are in such a compromised state of health that they actually fear and often actively oppose change. At least that's my personal impression. Don't you think this needs to be improved before some radical social change can actually take hold?
Yes. That's why I emphasize biology and health thinking to get people to realize that they're dying on this path and that they have to change something radically.
To simply save their own health, they've got to change the system, which is pumping. It isn't carbon dioxide. It's a thousand different toxins being pumped into the atmosphere and food supply that is killing people, vaccines and fake foods.
I think the movie Vaxxed and the various movements against genetically modified food and so on, that's a wedge that people can start to see their own survival and their children depending on bringing this industrial system
to some kind of safe conclusion.
Okay. In one of your first interviews with Danny, both of you were talking about panic and organizing the panic.
That actually might have been carried. But go ahead.
I think Dr. Peter opined on that as well. Let's say you're the average person on the street. You give them all this information. They say, "Okay. I see it in my own life. I believe you. I do understand that the system is killing me. I'm shaking with anxiety because I don't know what to do."
What would be your response to a person like that? Where do they start?
Getting organized. That's exactly where the power system exists. Any impulse towards organization gets interrupted.
All kinds of interruptions. Firing them from their jobs so they don't have access to the same resources. New ways of organizing have to develop.
Do you think that the cultural push in the Western world towards extreme individualism is a thinly veiled attempt at basically implementing this isolation so that people don't trust each other and refuse to organize?
Yeah. That's at the heart of preventing organization. In the 1930s, there was a religious movement called moral rearmament. That organization still exists.
It was a Christian movement with branches still in this country and in Europe. Religious reasons why you should destroy unions. It applies to any kind of social progress making change that impinges on the corporations and banks.
Right. But at the same time, organized religion is probably a prime example of organization, of getting people into groups and getting them to act upon a common goal.
It could go either way. If it's in the right hands, organization can be very powerful and impetus for change. But if it gets compromised from within by agents of the powers that be and whatnot, then people can be duped into sort of...
They think they're working towards the common good, but in reality, they're just maintaining the status quo.
Yeah. The CIA and the FBI are several stages ahead of everyone organizing anything you think of. They've got it covered. Like Occupy Wall Street, they put organizers in who help to prevent any constructive organizational outcome.
But they had snipers on the roofs ready to kill the leaders if anyone organized something that actually led to action.
Okay. Regular people are aware of that as well, many of them. They seem to have a choice between taking the risk at organizing and participating in a group and then this group being undermined and now they're working in favor of the empire versus avoiding participation in a bad activity, which you have also spoken in favor of in the past,
but then not really having enough power to enact change because they're on their own. Is there a middle ground or would it depend every single time on the situation?
I think it will change as cultural ideas evolve, but I think the first thing is to just start lots of organizations, two or three people in a group deciding on possible courses of action
and creating networks of just little personal interaction groups, but linking them up and being aware that the organizations have to stay flexible in terms of basically about a million little groups
with openness to interact with other groups on different levels.
So basically create a large number of smaller organizations that will be much harder to subvert just because the FBI doesn't have that much manpower?
Yeah, they've had maybe a million people attending to breaking up organizations, but if you have two million little groups developing, it will overwhelm their manpower advantage.
Like the communists used to say that for every actual communist party member, there were two or three FBI agents.
Yeah, I think that's what it sounds about right.
Well it seems like the FBI's ability and the CIA's ability to infiltrate movements is like co-Intel Pro and I don't know, Ruby Ridge and like promoting domestic terror and stuff or getting people to do things they otherwise wouldn't do.
Like what was that famous quote that like the FBI is behind most terrorist attacks in the US or something like that? Yeah.
Yeah, that has been documented over and over. The people throwing rocks in demonstrations are usually local police or FBI.
What was it, the Ferguson rap? Am I thinking of the right place? But there were provocateurs like breaking windows and they were flown in on planes to go like cause havoc during peaceful protests and stuff. So yeah.
And like in the Ukraine, there were snipers shooting both sides.
And then people are so politically charged that they can't kind of see the forest for the trees. And then it's like this bad ideology on top of the corruption and the infiltration of both sides.
Yeah.
I want to talk a little bit about consciousness.
Let's finish politics. Let's talk about consciousness. So we're up to about two hours. And so Ray, I don't want to keep you all day. Let's kind of end on consciousness.
And we have like 250 people listening right now. So Ray, Georgie, thank you so much for making this possible. Obviously a special live stream. So yeah, go for it, Georgie.
Yeah. In one of your books, actually, I think it was the Mind and Tissue where you said that consciousness at its very basis is the orienting reflex, right?
So my question relates to physiologically, what does that look like? Because there have been a number of studies coming out recently that are saying that medicine and neurology have been looking at consciousness the wrong way.
They're calling it the heart problem of consciousness because by analyzing the brain and all of the interactions of the neurons, they can't possibly explain the richness of personal experience.
And they call this thing qualia. And now they're proposing that maybe it's consciousness that's fundamental and it's a property of matter. It just varies in terms of its complexity depending on the object or the piece of matter that we're actually observing.
So there's an ancient Hindu proverb which says that the spirit of God sleeps in stone, dreams in animals, and awakens in men.
So my question is, how do you see that statement that consciousness is potentially a very basic property of matter and it's the complexity of the structure of this matter that determines how high level of this consciousness would be?
Does that sound about right?
Exactly. I formulated it that way in 1957 I think was the first time I said consciousness is the organized flow of energy through matter.
But I have revised it to think of consciousness as a substance in itself since substances are defined empirically, matter is defined empirically as we experience it.
I think it's proper to think of consciousness as a substance. For example, the donor-acceptor molecules contributing an electron flowing through muscle causes it to contract.
I think that same donor-acceptor relationship activates a constant oscillation of excited electrons through the neurons and between the neurons even.
It's a substance analogous to the conductive electron bands in metal, but the electrons are existing on the soft cytoplasmic material.
When the energy is properly activated by the oxidative acceptor function, raising electrons, creating holes basically for electrons to flow through the properly oxidized substance.
It's like having a fire get wet when you have too many electrons. It fills the holes and prevents the luminous function.
The perfume guy, I can't think of his name right now.
Tonini? Was it Tonini or no?
No.
It starts with a T, I think.
He sees odors as being resonant of the molecule, not the shape of the molecule but the electronic ability to resonate.
Going back to P.K. Anokin, for example, I think he saw his acceptor of action consciousness model as existing as an excited electron substance
which follows the rules of Gestalt psychology, actually space-filling material of electron plasma.
Actually, being what we experience, the light that we experience as red, white, blue, green, and so on, I think there is actually that frequency resonating in our brain tissue.
An odor, I believe the actual chemical pattern of that odor is what we experience, the consciousness of smelling a chemical.
That structure exists in space and each of the senses, I think, involves a certain frequency or energy level of the electrons.
So touch has a limited spatial ability.
The vision is the one that tends to be coherent, forming complexly coherent structures of meaning.
If I understand it correctly, as a result of metabolism, there is a directed electron flow from food to oxygen, right?
That donor-acceptor relationship causes the molecules in the cells to vibrate.
If they vibrate at the same frequency, I'm guessing a minimum base number of neurons, if they vibrate at the same frequency, that creates a resonance field, which is the basis of consciousness.
In one of his books, P.K. Anokin goes through a series of articles showing that the mechanical behavior of the auditory nerve, for example, can't carry the information that we actually experience flowing in on the auditory nerve.
He has various arguments showing that much more information is carried per second than nerve firing could possibly account for.
So it isn't information, it's actually the substance that we are experiencing.
Given the infinite richness of experience and the infinite richness of quality, wouldn't that imply that the brain cells would be capable of resonating at almost any frequency in order to reproduce that infinite richness of reality?
No, the frequencies have to be tuned very exactly. Something like the psychedelics can, in effect, create new, more extensive pathways, but I think the frequencies are all the same. It's just lubricating new connections that become richer.
So you're saying potentially the same frequency could create the experience of the color green, and then a different type of resonance, but with the same frequency, could create the experience of listening to Mozart, or something like that?
Yes, the green comes in all degrees of saturation, mere green or psychedelic, full spectrum green with meaning.
It resonates over into the feeling of religious meaning or the intensity of the meaning. It isn't just one frequency, one meaning. It's the intensity and saturation of that particular frequency.
Then the architectural structures built on those, so you could perceive Mozart or Beethoven almost at the level of descriptive, rational listening,
or you could have a full energy flow, like a hi-fi consciousness where all of the senses are resonating full intensity.
So basically the range of frequencies that the brain is capable of producing is limited, but their combination is infinite.
Yes, according to Anokin, the auditory frequencies are actually transmitting the full range of frequencies. A young person can actually experience all the way up to 35,000 or 40,000 cycles per second, like a porpoise.
Those are actually tuned processes of the electrons resonating at those actual frequencies.
The frequencies of nerve firing are nothing really related to consciousness. They are like the infrastructure maintaining energy production and substance distribution.
But the experience is floating over the infrastructure.
Speaking of resonance, I'm sure you're familiar with the publications of Rupert Sheldrake, I think is his name, about the morphogenetic fields and how we're essentially tapping into the same pool of knowledge.
Any single person learning enriches that pool of knowledge and then any other person could actually tap into that and get access to that new knowledge.
He's in this morphogenic tradition going all the way back to Goethe and earlier. But it's the actual living side of science, not the abstract, militarist, Platonist side of science.
So if two people are resonating, so to speak, if their consciousness are resonating and almost merging in a sense, is there a limit to the distance that these people can be separated with in order for this to occur?
Or is this like a global, universal phenomenon, no matter where these consciousness-capable pieces of matter are?
Puharich, did you ever read any of his books? Andrea Puharich?
I haven't.
He, I think, makes a satisfactory case for the whole earth resonance.
I think that the communication can probably be carried on like a carrier wave on the earth's resonance frequencies, modulating. I think each brain can modulate that carrier wave of the earth's electromagnetic field.
So the Schumann resonance frequencies could potentially be those carrier waves that allow for the unification of consciousness of organisms on earth?
Yeah, the Canadian psychologist who invented the God Helmet, an electronic helmet that stimulated the brain so that people had religious experiences.
Pershing?
Pershing, yeah. He suggests that we're tapping into the planetary carrier wave.
Okay, so since we're on the sort of like resonance of consciousness and distance, as you've written many times about David Bohm, and I'm a great fan of his work and writings, he was writing that it's actually a universal consciousness that we're all part of, and that there is a guiding pilot wave/carrier wave of which all of us are minor offshoots.
I didn't hear who you said.
David Bohm, the quantum physicist.
Oh, yeah.
And he was basically saying that there's two kinds of order, the implicate order and the explicate order, and then the explicate order arises out of the infinite implicate order in a creative manner, right?
And we've talked about this process of constant creation of both matter and meaning and knowledge. How do we participate in this creative process? Because do we also create matter ourselves? I mean, I know the earth does, the stars do, right? And probably the ethereal medium of the universe itself does, but how do we participate in that creative process?
I don't know.
David Bohm was of the opinion that we are integral to the creative process of the universe, but unfortunately he didn't elaborate how.
Yeah, I intuit that that's true, but I don't know how either. But I think it is most closely connected to this electronic jelly substance of consciousness or whatever is flowing through any substance according to its structure.
But N. A. Kozirev noticed that entities in the universe, stars, planets, moons, and so on, were emitting energy in proportion to their mass, and he believed that the passage of time was a source of energy.
But that simply says that energy comes out of the system, whatever matter is.
But he didn't have all of the planets' mass accurately connected to what was known about their emission of heat.
But just in recent years, the satellites have measured the emission of the outer big planets and found that there is an anomalous energy that corresponds to the mass rather than their position from the sun.
So it's a big confirmation of Kozirev's idea that the mere passage of time and any mass is going to be emitting energy.
So it's like we're all a fountain of energy of some sort.
So a question on Kozirev and stars, because actually that was the top question I was going to ask you tonight and you brought it up yourself.
As you know, he did a lot of experiments on measuring and creating time based on different processes.
So dissipating process that basically emit heat, he said that they produce time.
And that other processes that are sort of dropping in temperature, they can actually accept time.
They can absorb time.
So what do you think time is in terms of a physical entity?
My best guess is that Horace Dudley was right.
And he described it as the neutrino sea.
At that time, neutrinos were thought to have no energy, but he proposed that they do have energy and that they associate with matter according to its mass.
And that so-called nuclear energy is converting in conventional thinking, converting mass to energy.
Or in this view, it's simply being through time, passing through time as a mass that allows these neutrinos to interact.
And crystals, Horace Dudley suggested that the crystalline structure of matter was in some way in charge of how the neutrinos resonate.
That there's a space-filling resonance of neutrinos corresponding to the orderly arrangement of crystals that he suggested could cause nuclear reactions to occur unpredicted.
Simultaneously with his proposing that theory, an experimental physicist named Anderson observed that a monolayer of carbon isotopes on aluminum foil had a nonrandom nuclear decay.
Dudley had predicted that sort of thing, that an orderly arrangement of matter such as a surface would interact with the neutrino sea in a way that would draw on the energy of the nucleus.
Anyway, my inference from those two bits of data is that the brain, this structure of donor-acceptor activated gel of electrons,
my idea is that this structure of the brain is like the surface of the aluminum foil, able to tap into the energy of the neutrino sea.
This is where the introduction of novelty as well as energy comes from.
I read an interpretation of Aristotle recently that said that everybody has struggled with the definition of time, of what time is and how it relates to us.
Apparently Aristotle got pretty close. He said in one of his writings, apparently, I haven't seen the actual one, but he said that time is simply the amount of potentiality that has converted to actuality for any given system.
Does that sound about right?
Sounds right.
Okay, and last question related to consciousness.
If the stars are perhaps the most intense entities with the most intense metabolism, for lack of a better word, would you say that they possess a type of consciousness perhaps even higher than ours?
I would think a galaxy, the streaming shape creating forces of galaxies are probably conscious.
There's no more streaming energy through matter than the galaxy in action, but I think our brains are rivaling the galaxies for the complexity of activated substance.
We're trying to imitate the galaxy energy with actual physical creation of substance at the edge of the process.
That's remarkable. I don't know if you know, but Aristotle said that in his classification there were very few pure actualities. He said that humans, galaxies, stars, and I think he mentioned one other thing, cosmological, I'm forgetting what it is, but in his view those were the only actualities.
So he was placing them at the same level, I'm guessing, in terms of development as you are.
Yeah, that sounds right.
Okay. I don't have any other questions.
Speaking of, this is neither here nor there, but have you guys, there's like a special type of camera that's fairly new that can accurately zoom in on stars and planets, and the footage these people are taking of the stars and planets looks literally like nothing I've ever seen before, but they look like big balls of kind of multicolored energy.
Like that's how I would describe it, but Ray, are you familiar with that at all?
I'll forward you with them, but it's like, it's a lot of the flat earth people use it to say that NASA is lying about everything, but I think it's just interesting that we're actually, like just random people are able to take a really interesting video of stars.
Okay. So I guess we'll end it there. Let me just read. So Ray, I don't know if you know how it works, but people do super chats and a big group of people have accumulated $794.
So whatever YouTube takes of that, I will forward to you, Ray, and I appreciate you being on here.
And let me just read. We won't be able to get to people's questions because we would be on here for hours.
And so Oscar Gomez, Oscar Gomez, TC, Intelligent Evolution, Anna Tanska, Intelligent Evolution, Christina Tomaj, Matthew Riley, Matthew Riley again, Ruth Cazzo, Kirk333, Zuburg, Kirk333 again, Chris H, Harrison Ben, Gene Philippe, Groh, Kind Sign, I'm butchering that name, Matthew Riley, Harry Burgos, Harrison Ben, Harrison Ben again,
Francis Bacon Cheeseburger, Harrison Ben, Sandy, Miss T, Roger Chair, HT, New Health, Michael, Veronica Ayala, New Health, Veronica Ayala again, Yanny Matraskastas, Elliot Cactus, Elliot Cactus again, huge Ray Peet fan, huge Ray Peet fan again, Milk and Honey, Milk and Honey again, Milk and Honey, multiple, so many people.
Multiple super chats from Milk and Honey, thank you for that. Monty did multiple super chats, thank you for that. Gio, thank you for that. Turkish Postman, I think we just got one more, DBO514, thank you guys so much.
I apologize for not being able to read your questions. Georgie and I can like devote an entire episode to trying to answer these questions. Any parting words, Ray? Can you tell people how to obtain your newsletter?
You can email RayPeetsNewsletter@gmail.com and see if you can have people come up with ideas and create new organizations.
I love it, I love it. So, and then Georgie, any parting words?
A question for Dr. Peet in terms of ideas for scientific studies that he thinks are worth replicating. I mean, I haven't mentioned it, I mentioned in previous podcasts with Danny, but I'm privileged enough to start being able to make my own studies and I was thinking of doing one on essential fatty acid depletion and trying to prove that all of the, because there's only one by the Burrs in the 1930s.
So, I'm trying to prove that really all of these symptoms of fatty acid, essential fatty acid deficiencies that we're seeing were just deficiencies of specific nutrients and maybe insufficient amount of calories and things like that.
Anything else, any other seminal idea that you think is really currently being twisted and poisoning the scientific and the medical world that we can try and test and sort of show the exact opposite?
If I think of something, I'll contact you.
Okay, understood. Thank you.
Awesome. Ray, stay on the line. I'm going to kind of wrap things up. Guys, thank you so much. Like 250 people in the chat right now. Guys, sincerely appreciate it. Thank you so much to Ray for making this possible and just being endless inspiration and such a humble guy.
I'm sure I can't speak for only for myself, but changing so many people's lives. Thank you, Georgie, for doing the show with me so often. This is just a special live stream. So, thank you guys so much for making this possible.
Ray, stay on the line. We'll talk to you after and I'm going to wrap things up here. Everybody, thank you so much. We'll see you guys. I'll see you next week, I think, with Tim. Okay, guys, take care. Thank you.
[Music]
Oh.
(upbeat music)